what is up everybody it's annamac here
for
anime outpour and the moment we've all
been waiting for
for a very long time is finally here
the dark secrets of the mysterious one
for all quirk have just been revealed to
deku and we
finally know why all might deliberately
chose to hide information about the
fourth
one for all user from deku as it turns
out
one for all has serious consequences for
its users
and deku might end up being the very
last
user of one for all this was a crazy
chapter
so much important information was
revealed so let's get into it
if you enjoyed the boku no hero content
on this channel and you want us to keep
it going do me a favor
leave a like and comment and if you are
new to anime out pro or maybe you watch
our videos but you haven't subscribed
yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications the
only way to make sure that you will
actually see my future videos and that
you won't miss them
is to take the time to subscribe hit
that notification bell
and then select the option that says all
you can also hit me up on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
finally this video will of course
contain boku no hero manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution
you have been warned the new chapter
starts off with the still unconscious
deku wondering what happened to everyone
after the big battle in jakku but rather
than waking up
deku finds himself once again inside
that mysterious
vestige world there all of the previous
users of one for all
are waiting for him and daigo robonjo
explains that before
deku wakes up they have to talk to him
about something important
actually i shouldn't say all of the
previous one for all users are waiting
for deku two of them are just chilling
in the back
and they're facing away from deku and
towards the wall
these are the second and third users of
one for all
and i'm sure that this is supposed to be
symbolic of the fact that we still don't
know anything about them and that they
are still a mystery to us
but to be honest to me it just looks
like those two are in the process of
taking a leak
am i the only one who thinks they look
like they're taking a leak anyway
the first user of one for all explains
that in the past the
former users could only interact with
deku when he was severely mentally
shaken
but in the past four months the power of
one for all has been growing
exponentially and
this has enabled the former users to
communicate more effectively
with each other and with deku it also
seems that
all for one's infiltration into the
vestige world during the battle of jakku
has made it easier for the former users
to get in touch with deku
deku's own manifestation inside the
vestige world
is still incomplete and in particular he
still doesn't have a mouth
however it seems that his voice is
slowly manifesting itself
within this realm and he is now able to
make some noises
although his words are still muffled we
then see
that mysterious fourth user of one for
all
the one with the mark on his face that
makes him look like a character from
mashall
and the one whose information was
partially scribbled out
by all might the fourth user explains
that his name is
shinomori hagake and that he will be
doing the talking
this time around the latest quirk that
deku was able to manifest
danger sense used to belong to shinomuri
back when he was still alive the fourth
user of one for all was somewhat of a
hermit who lived in the woods
far away from society shinomori explains
that it was a turbulent time
and so for him living the life of a
hermit wasn't weird at all
under the circumstances in fact everyone
who didn't choose that lifestyle was
kind of weird as far as shinomori was
concerned
the fourth user then explains that he
died at the age of
40 and that his cause of death was
old age that is the missing piece of
information that
all might chose to hide from deku
shinomori the fourth user of one for all
died of
old age when he was only 40 years old
and the reason why he died of old age
while he was still so young
is one for all itself deku is confused
when he hears this
but shinomuri explains that he held one
for all for a long time about
18 years and in the final year of his
life
the quirk simply broke his body
one for all may be an incredibly
overpowered quirk that makes its user
very strong
but it has one extremely dangerous side
effect it appears to slowly but surely
burn away the life force of its own
holders deku is shocked to hear this and
he is
understandably concerned but then he
asks an
important question if one for all really
does have
this side effect then how was all might
able to use it way longer than shinomori
without dying of
old age at first the formal holders
didn't even know the answer to this
themselves and during this conversation
the first holder
over one's brother reveals that he
himself died in battle
not long after gaining the power of one
for all so even though he was the first
user
he wasn't exactly an expert on how one
for all worked
however once they all put their heads
together inside the vestige world
the former users eventually arrived at
the answer
the thing that made all might different
from all the other previous users
and the thing that allowed him to use
one for all for so long without
destroying his body is the simple fact
that all might
was quirkless those who are born with a
quirk
already have their metaphorical cup full
and so
adding one for all an additional quirk
to that
cup makes the cup spill over this is
what happened
to shinomori having one quirk and then
adding one for all on top of it
was too much for his body to handle so
his body simply burned
out under the pressure of so much quirk
power
but because all might was born quirkless
his body simply recognized one for all
as his true quirk and so his body wasn't
overloaded by it as it turns out despite
the fact that they are often looked down
upon in society
those individuals who are born quirkless
are the ones who have the most potential
when inheriting the power of one for all
this means that deku is safe for the
time
being as a quirkless individual himself
he should be able to handle one for all
for a long period of time
without burning out just like all might
was able to do
unless the one for all quirk keeps
changing as it seems to be doing
and those changes eventually put deco at
risk at some point in the future
we have to be open to that possibility
as well because one for all has been
evolving and growing exponentially we
just learned that
in this chapter so you never know what
the long-term consequences
of that evolution might be deku is safe
for now
but that may change in the future if the
growth of one for all spirals
out of control at any rate the former
holders of one for all
have arrived at an important conclusion
from now on they cannot risk
passing one for all on to someone who
already possesses a quirk
ever again from now on one for all must
only be passed down to individuals who
were born quirkless
but with every new generation the number
of quirkless people continues to
decrease
this means that deku could be the very
last
successor of one for all by the time
that deku is ready to pass the quirk on
to someone else
there may not be any eligible candidates
left and this might be the end
of one for all after this shocking twist
that leaves deku
reeling nanashimura steps up and lays a
very heavy burden right on deku's
shoulders
she asks deku whether he is able to kill
tomorrow shigaraki for her and that
is how this crazy info packed
chapter ends wow this
is big we just learned that one for all
has been slowly killing its own users
all the way up to the time that all
might inherited the quirk
as the first quirkless inheritor he was
able to use the quirk for a long time
and he was able to become strong enough
to stand up to
all for one and since deku was also born
quirkless
he definitely has the potential to
become as strong as
all might but we have to acknowledge the
important
implications of these huge revelations
on deku
and on the wider story not only does
this mean that deku might be the very
last
one for all user and that the quirk may
one day die
with him but this also means that if the
quirk continues to change and evolve
exponentially as it has been doing in
recent months
then eventually even deku's quirkless
body
may begin to burn out under the strain
of one for all
don't forget that this quirk is still
getting stronger and it is still growing
and expanding
so we can't just assume that deku will
be 100
safe from the negative effects of one
for all just because he didn't have a
quirk
before he inherited this quirk he is
safe for now
but that could change now a big question
that i am asking myself
after this chapter is why were the other
two one for all users
the second and third user just standing
in the back
and taking a leak why don't they feel
the need to communicate with deku
as everyone else seems to feel or is it
that they can't communicate with them
for some reason these were the two users
of one for all who came right after all
for one's brothers so who were they
and why are they hiding their faces
is it possible that while they were
alive they did some shady stuff
and because of that they are hiding
their identities
or are they hiding from deku because he
is not
ready to meet them and learn about their
quirks
like maybe these guys had really
powerful quirks that deku can't handle
yet
and so they can't communicate with him
until he is
ready or you know maybe they were just
taking a leak i also thought that it was
interesting that all might's
consciousness
or at least some fragment of it is also
present
in that vestige world even though all
might is still alive
and even though he never had a quirk
this suggests
that the consciousnesses themselves are
not directly tied to the user's
original quirk factor and so they must
arise
either from one for all itself or from
all for one
who was of course instrumental in
creating one for all in the first place
i am very curious to find out more about
the true nature of the vestiges
and how these consciousnesses are able
to survive even after the death
of the individuals they belong to and i
am sure that the answer to this question
will also be relevant to all for one
becoming an uninvited guest
in shigaraki's body finally what did you
guys think about
nana's question does she really want
deku to kill her own grandson
does she really believe that shigaraki
is completely
beyond saving and if she does do you
think that deku would actually be able
to straight up kill someone
even if that person is a villain or is
that maybe a line that deku would simply
not cross
even if that means allowing shigaraki to
continue hurting innocent people
definitely let me know what you guys
think about these important questions
down in the comments below this was a
great
chapter and i always love learning more
about the mysterious nature
of one for all we did learn a lot in
this
chapter but at the same time there is
still a lot that we don't know about one
for all
i'm sure we're gonna find out even more
about it in the future including more
about those two mysterious one for all
users who are hiding their faces
and personally i'm very excited for that
time to come if you guys enjoyed this
video and you want to see more boku no
hero content here on the channel
don't forget to leave a like it really
does help and if you are new to anime
opera
or maybe you haven't subscribed yet make
this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications don't forget that you
really have to go through the trouble of
subscribing hitting the bell
and then clicking that option that says
all if you don't do that you're gonna
miss a ton of our videos in the future
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter and
instagram at animeopror a big thank you
to all of our anime uproar patrons for
making videos like this one
possible special thank you to alpha
sigma
disciple of lord twigo himself and i
can't forget all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above all
other clans including ingrata the world
a quiet respect pate heffa liam thompson
algertol dr cortman johnny boy draws
emperor otaku spidey life chanel baked
buddhist and
tungsten tarkis finally thank you also
to our pro hero tier patrons including
the one and only gilgamesh steelers on
hell crews anatoly kazatsky
joe stanton very gucci jessica califond
rathune de ora alicia octor bonnie parks
hinokami and water the red-haired raven
joanne garcia jack watches anime fat boy
games ted no ted deadly saint matthew
cruz and
anthony schreiber if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value for you consider supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patreon exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you